はい まあちょっとあの
もっとこれからは簡単です
で これから音楽的になれる
なれるという まあ一般的な考え方ができます
で 論理的な具体的なアプローチ
デマーケーションオブラーニングアンドトレーニングという
ハードな道に裏の手はないということで
何でも習ってしまえば良いと思って
オウム返しのような勉強は決して良くない
習っちゃえば簡単やと言ってやるなよ
そんなことはということで
頭は良くならないし 丸暗記しておいても役に立たない
だから物事を何でもかんでも丸暗記するんじゃないんで役に立たない
現代では優れたデータバンクもロボットもいるから
人間はロボットになる必要はありません
これから現代人 だから物事いっぱい覚えたんだからといって役に立たないんですよ
ただのデータバンク なんで人間データバンクなるなるで
いっぱいでもデータバンクあるでしょ
だからまあいりません
それから習慣つけちゃって
習慣に乗っ取ってロボットのように動くと
これもいらないんですよ
人間なら創造的に動いた方がいいんです
大事なのは物事の理解能力と
それはどのように使用するかという発想なのです
で これが大事なことなんですね
物事は理解して この理解能力は我々がどのように使えばよろしいかと
人間のために 自分のために
ために その発想がすごく大事なんです
それでは慣れるということ
慣れるというと何なのかと
慣れるということは 辞書を暗記しても外国語は話せませんよ
やってる人はいますけどね
辞書を暗記したっても
もう慣れることは知識に関係はありません
だから慣れることと知識はちょっと関係なくなっちゃうんですね
慣れることだけ集中しちゃうと
慣れるとは人格に道徳に関係あるものです
だから慣れるって何なのかというと
知識と関係ない 微妙ですかね
言ってることは 知識っていうのは理解ですから
一部慣れますけど 理解は大事に優先しなくちゃいけない
慣れるということは 人格と道徳なんです
大学 学校の勉強じゃないんです
学問の場合も必ずしも必要ですが
全てではありません 人格向上
道徳の場合も理解が必要だが
それだけでは何の役にも立たない
例えば嘘を言っては悪いと
これはわかってますよと
意味がないでしょうに
わかってますよと言っても
だから道徳の場合はわかっただけでは役に立たない
慣れてほしい 学校の勉強の場合は丸暗記するなよと理解しなさいと
だから わかりやすく言えば
学問 知識は習う 道徳は慣れる
その時は区別できます
で 人格向上 道徳は理解しただけで守りにくいものです
道徳なんか分かっただけではね
守れませんよ 酒は体に悪いとわかってもね
だからってやめられますかね
やめられないでしょう
ずっと長い間酒飲んできていた人と賭け事はずっとやってきて
自己破産もして そうしちゃうと
その人わかってますよ
これが悪かったと でもそれでもお金があったらまた何かに賭ける
だから分かっただけで道徳は守りにくい
分かっていてもついやってしまうのは人間です
たとえ真面目な信頼できる人間でも
間違いを犯す可能性があるのです
人間というのは真面目ですごい信頼できる人でいたっても
どこかでまた道が外れて
なんとか間違いを犯す
国会議員であろうとも
何でも痴漢はしてしまうということはあります
別にそんな大胆なことでも驚くべきことでも
ごく普通なことなんですよ
私にしてみれば 本当は人間ってそんなもの
わかっちゃうと その人のことをそんなにガチャガチャ言う必要ないでしょうに
言ってる連中はもっとひどいなのに
だからまあ その人もごく普通の人間で
酔って酒に酔っちゃって
まだ元気でしょうし 若いでしょうし
まあ女の子見たら まあちょっとちょっと手を出しちゃっていくぐらいことかもしれません
すごいことになったら
その人も訴えるでしょうね
女の子を含めて まあまあいいや
そんなじじいということでね
まあなんとか一言で怒ってあげば済むものです
だからまあ日本はすごい大げさなことにしましたけど
まあ一応人間っていうのはそんなもんですよ
いくら議員さんやと言ったっても
なんかやっちゃうということをやってしまうっていうことはね
あり得る 道徳的に人格的には
人間は曖昧で中途半端な存在です
道徳になってくると 人間は曖昧
曖昧 中途半端 嘘は私は嘘をつかないんだよと言っても
それ自体は嘘 それ言っちゃうと怒られる
もう大変ですよ 一番 今思い出したんですけど
このヨーロッパ型のこの菜食主義者がいるんですよ
ヨーロッパ型で言ってるのは
結構ヨーロッパ人がやってるんだからなんです
人気もあります 菜食主義には
あの連中はもう心の問題じゃないんですよ
物質にかかってるんです
この子の物質 物質を食べて
この子の物質は食べてはいけないと
厳密に顕微鏡で見て分けるんですよ
それで肉魚食べないんだから牛乳も飲めない
それで食パン食べるかというと
裏を見て バター あ いや
私は食べません バター使ってるんだったらもう食べません
それでも怒るわ 人を馬鹿にするわ
私と一緒に食べてるところで
私はバター塗ってあったっていうのは別にまあまあ
それで食べますけど 何かブーソーのくせにね
なんたることでしょうかと
あなた方はすごい偉大なるこの文化を教えて知っていると思っていたのにとかね
何様ですよ こういう人は
と私はヨーロッパ人に全然もう平気でも気にしないんだからね
言いたいことをぐちゃぐちゃ言うんですね
結局もうそれからこっち
いくらなんでも私から学ばなくちゃいけない
ある人は言うんですよ
もう私は宗教大事なんだよと
今からインドも大好きやと
別にと言ったんで 私はありがとうございます
それはとてもとても聞いて楽しいとか
そんなことなんか私は反応しませんだからね
なんだよと言ったんですよ
やっぱりそういう国には
いかがでしょうかね あまり肉魚は食べないは菜食主義で
まあ菜食主義やと何とかではなく
先には肉魚とかないんだよ
だから食べてないんだ
ただそういうことで まあなんとかなんとかすごくいいんじゃないかなとかね
どんどん話すと腹が立ってきたんですよ
私は言ったんだ あなたは今牛乳も食べない
飲まない 食パンも食べないでしょ
あなたの体見てくださいと
ものすごいもう体格があってね
あなたは 13  18歳になってきたまで食べた肉の量は
牛なんと食べたんでしょうかと
あなた あの国の人々はもうもう 10人まとめて一生計算したっても
それぐらいあなた一人ぐらい食べてないんだよと
だから私は心配しているのは
自分の子供たちは栄養失調やと
エラそうなあれこれやと
向こうでもすごい運動
なんですよ 肉食べてはあかんとか
牛肉食べてはあかんとかね
でも鶏食べては？私は子供は卵ぐらいは食べてほしいや
もう体が栄養失調で頭が悪くなるわ
それで国全体的に傾くわ
そういう主義やと これでそんなこと攻撃しようとするでしょうに
知らない こちらは攻撃にはかなわない相手やと
どんな攻撃かっても まあまあ
それで結構まあ人はどんどんどんどん心が変わってるんで
長い間もう付き合ってはいたんですけど
で 逆にものすごい怒る
自分食べるところに隣誰かが肉とマンとか食べてちゃう
それだけで自分が侮辱したんだと
この人知ってるんだと
私はもうもうベジタリアンであることにも関わらず
それでパクパク食べながら喋るんだと
そうすると飛んでくるんだと
この人は人を憎んで怒りで
もうただ物理的に物質的にこれは食わない
これは食うぐらいの区別なんで
そんなのは道徳でも何でもないんですよ
だから大事なのは人格向上
道徳なんですよ 良い人間になってればならないかと
ヨーロッパ方の菜食主義者はみんなそういう菜食主義者で
我々東洋人が思うような
命を大事にする 命を愛する
命を尊いものだと思う気持ちはひとかけらもない
それである日責めたんです
あなたの優しさっていうのはちょっとおかしいと
責めたところで平気で言うんですよ
まあ私はまあ 動物ならまあいくらでも愛することはできますよ
いくら邪魔されたってでも
蚊でもゴキブリでも人間の場合はできませんよ
動物を愛して人間肉を食むっていうことは
どれほど悪人でしょうかと
本人には気づかないんです
仲間でしょうに 人間というのは
私はね あんたの間違いはそこですよ
あんた真っ先に人間を愛することを勉強したら
それ分変わりますよ あんた残酷な人間やと
今も今より残酷やと 肉食べてた時代と比べると道徳的に衰えたと
すごいブレイクダウンやと
これモラリ で 動物をあなたを助けたとごちゃごちゃ言っても
あなたは人間どれほど助けたと先に考えてないんだと
生まれてから ものすごい人間に助けられて
人間の社会で生きていて
日本で会った人なんですけど
それはきれいさっぱり忘れて
動物の世界をすごい心配して愛するんだと
まあ自分を助けられたのは
まあ自分が食っちゃった鶏と牛肉ぐらいでしょうに
まあその数よりはもう人間はすごい助けてあげてるでね
だからそこで道徳的には本当にもうブレイクダウンですよ
そういうこの形式的な形だけの世界は仏教でない
だから理解してくれないのは残念ですけども
ものすごいもう知識で知恵で
もう論理的に問題を見るんですよ
形だったらわかりやすいでしょうに
それでビスケットをあげても
パッケージをあげないと
その人にぱっとじーっと読むんですよ
植物性脂肪を使ってるんだよと思ったら食べる
だから人間の道徳っていうのは
あ 覚えたね えーと 曖昧で
中途半端  その方は別な
ちょっと極端な例で まあ我々にしたっても
もうすごい立派な曖昧なんですよ
まあ非道徳的な人間だけど
そうではないでしょう
すごい社会の決まり守って
まあ道徳守って紛れにはいるんですけど
まあ立派な曖昧で もうわからないんですね
嘘をついてるかといったって
もうちょっと困るし では日本人信頼できないのかというとそうでもないし
信頼はできるだったら嘘つく
で 嘘つく いつでももうそういう社会ですね
人間の社会は だから人類は道徳的には中途半端で曖昧です
日本の特色といえば 知識的にも中途半端なんですけど
あれはかっこ悪いんですよ
道徳的な中途半端は別にどうったことね
これ誰でも同じだからね
知識的にはイエスのはっきりしないとものすごいかっこ悪い
まあ道徳的な 今神社にも行くし
お寺にも行く そんなのはどうでもいいんですよ
それで教会にも行くんだと
それは決してかっこ悪くないんです
そこら辺曖昧 曖昧やと
外国人にあんたは曖昧じゃないか
あんたどんな宗教かと
これ俺もわからないんだと
もうたまたま立派な神社があったんだからお祈りしましたと
たまたま立派な教会があったんだから行ってお祈りしたんだと
それでかっこいいんです
それがかわいいんです
なぜならば もともと人間っていうのは道徳的にはもうしっかりしない
しかしまあ 知識的にはしっかりしてほしいですね
その曖昧さがあるんだからこそ
道徳の場合は慣れる 習うんじゃないんです
心は本来悪に慣れているのです
よく覚えてください 我々の心は本来悪なんですよ
まあ子供は良い人間も悪い人間もどっちでもないと言ったでしょ
前は だから学校は人格を作らなくちゃいけないんだと
学校はそれ取り消してるでしょ
学校でも道徳教育はなし
まあ良い人間になることはもう後回しにすると
確実に悪い人間に育てるんです
なぜかというと もう心は悪に慣れてるんですよ
生まれる前から だから悪は簡単ですよ
悪は人間にとって自然なもので
抜け道さえあれば喜んで犯すんですよ
悪を犯すっていうことは
我々のすごい自然なんですよ
身についてるんです もう癖なんです
だからちょっと抜け道があればやっちゃうんですよ
法律があるわ 親が見ているわ
先生が見ているわ 人が見ているわ
だからやれないだけ みんな見ているんだから
ちょっと逃げる道があったらやるっていうの
それ普通です 善人でいることは大変難しい
だからいい人間でいるそうと思っても
これすごい難しい 善人でいるために努力すると
自分自身の心の感情と葛藤するのです
それで人が私はやっぱり良い人間になると頑張るでしょ
でも心の中からもう葛藤が生まれますよ
やりたいんですよ 本当は
やりたいんだけど もうやらない
やらない やらないと決まってるんだからね
真面目に頑張ってますけど
自分の心との戦いはやっぱり厳しいんですよ
気持ちの感情の戦いとは
社会から誘惑にも勝てなく
それだけじゃない 周りからもう誘惑するでしょうに
悪に良いことに誘惑しないんです
心配しないでください
もう悪だったらいくらでも誘惑はあるんです
だから大変ですよ 道徳守るということは
人格向上は ですから 道徳に慣れてしまえば簡単です
だから道徳の場合は慣れてしまう
あの復習 復習してして
まあ犬はお手と言った途端に手を挙げるでしょ
別に何も考えてないんですよ
もう自動的にそこをそういうふうになるまで道徳になれるんですよ
それがブッダが説く正しい方法なのです
嘘つかない タバコを吸わない
酒飲まない 殺生しない
邪まな行為しない 怠けない
怒らない 欲張らない 嫉妬しないなどなど
時間かけて説得すれば
普通はダメと言うでしょう
時間かけてかけて そういう人に教えてあげれば
決めるんで ああ わかりました
やめない やめますよと
それは簡単ですけど しかし瞬時に忘れる
人に嘘をつく人はいけないということを説得するために
させるためにはすごい難しいんですよ
これで何時間もかけて
何日もかけてやっと説得したならば
本人がわかりました 説得に納得いきました
私は嘘をつかないことにしましたと
すぐ忘れる そんなもんだ
そこで嘘をつかないと無理をするのではなく
無理をせず慣れてしまうのです
酒を飲まないことに慣れてしまう
例えば 酒飲んだ人は酒をやめると決めた
決めたら慣れる その人生に
酒飲まない人生に 私のスケジュールにはそういう項目はありませんと
だから心の中でも まあ酒飲まないで思うこと思うのもないんですよ
朝はこれやって すぐにこれやって
それ終わってから会社から帰ってからすぐにお風呂に入って
テレビはこれぐらい見て
あの本も読んで それから寝ると
それ自分のスケジュール
それそのスケジュールで
あ 酒を飲まない 飲まないことにしましたから
じゃあ酒はやめてと入ってはダメなんですよ
だからまるっきり新しい訓練で
新しい世界でずっといるんですよ
そうすると何のことなくマンネリになっちゃうんですよ
何が？酒飲まないことが
楽ですよ 何の無理も感じない
自分の普通の生活スタイルになるまでなれるのです
自分の生活スタイルになるまで道徳を訓練しなくてはいけない
そうすると無理なく守られるし
本当に善人になっています
それで初めて道徳が身につく
善人になる 良いことをしているという実感が消えるまでなれるのです
私は嘘をつかないんだからいい人間やと思っているとダメなんですよ
まだまだ誘惑はあるんですよ
この場合は怒らない 怒らない
怒らないよとかね 頑張っているとダメなんですよ
別にもうそんな感じもない
なくなったところでいいことやっているという感じ
消えたところでもう道徳はもう完成しているところなんです
道徳は時間かけて守ると
悪い心が良い心に変わるのです
だから心の復習 だから世界ではないんです
世界は脳細胞と肉体しか知らないんだから
これ心の復習なんですよ
道徳をね だから道徳を守ることを復習すると
復習するともう心がもう変わってしまうんですね
悪い心が良い心に入れ替えてしまいますね
舌を噛んででも 泣きながらでも
道徳になれることはとても大事だと釈尊が説くのです
だから最初は厳しいんだよと
嘘をつかないと言っても軽々く決めるなよと
これかなり厳しいんですよ
厳しくても 舌を噛んででも
泣きながらでも守ってみなさい
心にも体にも 復習するものは習慣になる特色があるのです
だから心にも体にも脳は書いてないんですけど
まあそういう特色があるんですよ
復習するものは習慣になるんですね
だから嘘をつかないことを復習すると
習慣になってしまいます
道徳人格の場合は 復習こそが道なのです
だから慣れる道は道徳のためなの
道徳の世界観です 仏教ではいつでも理解
智慧が優先です 道徳も理解さえあれば守ることは苦にならない
理解すれば苦にはなりませんが
嘘を言うことは本当に良くないとよく理解すると
まあ苦にはなりません
しかし 最高たる智慧の土台は
道徳論理なので 初めから挑戦するべきものなんですよ
家建てる前に土台でしょ
だから悟るまで待ってはいけませんよ
最初から道徳に挑戦するんです
悟ってから悪を犯さない人間になるから
今は無視してもいいというわけにはいきませんね
私は悟ってから嘘をつかないことにしますよと
一体話にならん 今やってもいいことになるんだから
今煩悩あるんだからしょうがないでしょうと
話にならん 煩悩あるんだからって悪いことしていいわけじゃないんですよ
だからこれは人格の土台なんですね
道徳は だから悟るか悟るまいか置いといて
まず土台を作る それは厳しい
嘘をついたいんだから
嫉妬したいんだから 人を殴りたいんだからね
だからそこをやめることから苦しいんだけど
復習すると復讐するともう自然になってしまう
道徳はだから道徳はなれるものです
知識と知恵は習うことから始めて
最後に体験するんです
知識 知恵は習うことから始めて体験するものです
最終的には習うことも慣れることも一緒になるのです
知識と知恵っていうのは
もう勉強することから始まるんです
道徳は最初からもう慣れてもらう
まあ理屈はいらんと ブッダの言葉
アビッターレータカリアネーパパチッタニバーエダンダンヒカロートープンヤンパパスミンラマトーラマティーマノー
今言ったことのブッダの言葉なんで
今説明したんですけどね
良い行いを好きになること
良い行いにされて好きになってほしいと
心を悪から離すこと のんびり善行をすると心が悪に慣れてしまうからです
憧れてしまう 憧れてしまうからです
心は初めから悪が好きでしょうに
だから善に善を好きにしなさいよと
良いこと好きだよと 楽しいんだよ
私の娯楽だよと 人を助けることやら
いろんないいことすることは
それは私の娯楽ですと
酒飲むことじゃないんだと
そういう風にした方がいいんだと
なぜかというと まあたまたま趣味で良いことをしたっても
ちょっと危ない 心はもう悪に落ちてしまうんです
パパンチェプリソカイラナタンカイラプナプナンナタンミチャンダンカイラートドゥッコパパッサウッチャヨ
パーパンチェプリソカイラナタンカイラプナプナンナタンミチャンダンカイラートドゥッコパパッサウッチャヨ
たとえ悪を犯してしまっても
それを繰り返し しないこと
まあたまたまみんなやっちゃいますけどね
それはたまたまにして繰り返しは絶対しない
もう二度とやらんということにするんです
それを好きにならないこと
だからすごく嫌に感じた方がいいんですよ
悪いことをしてしまった
なんて情けないんですかと
かっこ悪いんだと 嫌いになった方がいいんです
なぜなら 悪が積むことは苦しみである
悪がどんどん増えると
もうすごい輪廻の苦しみが待ち構えている
次の言葉 パーパンチェープリソーカイラカイラーテータンプナックプナン
タンミチャンダンカイラーテースコープンニャッセウッジャヨ
パーパンチェープリソーカイラカイラーテーナンタンプナックプナン
もし善行為をしたならば
それを繰り返し行うこと
たまたまでもいいことをしたら
またまたまだまだまだまだ繰り返してほしい
同じこと それを好きになること
すごい好きになってしまう
なぜなら 功徳が積むことは幸福ですと
お釈迦様のこの説法は
私は前説明した法則にのっとって教えているんです
心は本来は悪 悪に傾く
傾いている だから悪は好きになるのはわかっている
だからわざと善行為を好きになる
好きになって繰り返す
繰り返して復習する 復習すると心が善心になってしまう
マーマッンエーテパーパッスナマンタンアーガミッサティ
ウダビンドゥニパーテーナウダクンボーピポーラティ
ポーラティバーローパーパッストーカトーカンピアーチナン
マーラマンエーテパーパッスナマンタンアーガミッサティ
ウダビンドゥニパーテーナウダクンボーピポーラティ
ポーラティバーローパーパッストーカトーカンピアーチナンって言葉
向くわけじゃない そうと罪を軽視してはならない
軽くしてはいけないんですよ
なぜかというと  1滴ずつ落ちてでも
水瓶は満杯になる 大きな水瓶があって
これで屋根が雨が漏って
あまり大げさな漏れじゃないんだけど
たまに一滴だけぽつんと散るだけ
それでも時間経つと水瓶がいっぱいなんですよ
そのようにちょこちょこと悪いことをした
して まあ馬鹿にする まあそんな向くわけないでしょ
なんとかとかね やがて悪になるんですよ
これ復讐機能ですよ そのように少しずつ積んだ
積んで愚か者は罪で満杯になる
だから愚か者はね 悪を馬鹿にしちゃって
軽視しちゃって 大胆な悪をしませんよ
銀行強盗とか人殺しとかね
そんなことはやってないんだけど
ちょこちょこちょこちょこっとやっていて
結局はいっぱいになるんですよ
死ぬ時は悪人になってしまうんです
だから問題は 一生良い人間にいた人が
45歳で人殺したりする
それで捕まられて 審判裁判を受けて
まあ残りの人生は刑務所にいる
他の人々はごく普通で
ちょこっとちょこっと悪いことするんだけど
もうもう法律ではもう別にもうもう捕まれない
誰もそれを気にしない
そういうちょこちょこっと悪いこと
でも見つけてないんですよ
誰にも 結局は死ぬ時は誰が罪重いんですかね
わからないんですよ この人一生ちょこちょこちょこ溜まったし
あの人は一生一回しかやってないんで
それはちょっとスケール大きかった
でも刑務所で罪を起こせないし
今までもやったことはないし
もしかするとその人の方が軽いかもよ
いい人間に生きてる人よりはいい人間だと思って
だからそれすごい気をつけた方がいいポイントなんです
一般のいい人間の方々は
本当にいい人間だと罪を軽視してちょこちょこちょこやってるんではないか
そのちょこちょこやってることは毎日やってるんだからね
足してみればかなり量になるんです
法律では裁けませんだけど
業ではもう因果法則だから結果が出る
あで結論で終わりと思いますけど
道徳人格向上に限って言うならば
これこれに限って言うならば
仏教は習うようになれる
だからすべてじゃなくて
道徳 人格向上 しかし 人格向上の頂点は悟りなんですね
ということになるんです
今日はどうもありがとうございます
はい